you know it's so easy to say like you
know we put so much time and effort it
you know before we launched the pitch
video I'm just really curious what kind
of time are we talking about you know
cuz you know we know you know Karen I
know that kind of uh so that you to put
in you know you see it when you walk in
here and it's a joke productions but in
terms of a pitch video what will give me
give us some guidelines give you give us
give us like the amount of time that
really should be put into it well okay
it's a two-part I think it's a two-part
question because it's the time that it
actually takes before you're ready to do
a pitch video and then the physical time
and thanks to do the video I think in
the case in our case like our
Kickstarter was part of a much bigger a
much bigger thing that we started two
years earlier which was to start a blog
to hopefully contribute something useful
to the community to to be out there you
know not building an audience but
hopefully building goodwill and and
giving as much of ourselves as we could
in the hopes that you know when it came
time for us to do a campaign we would
have a lot of friends and a lot of
people that we had helped and a lot of
other campaigns that we had supported
that might be willing to you know to
help us and to feel like we deserve to
be able to ask for that help
so before we ever got to the point of
spreading the word and that's it yeah
you know helping build the community
yeah not only building the community for
your film but just being part of the
being part of whatever community is
you're working in in general whether for
us that was being part of the cancer
community as related to the movie or
part of the filmmaking community is just
trying to give back with tips and tricks
and little things we learned along the
way so I think that you you know you
really need to be able to to know in
your heart that you've given a lot
before you've asked and I think that
that allows you to ask for more and feel
good about it because you know that you
would give just as much if someone asks
for your help when it comes down to the
nitty-gritty of making the video I do
think it's really important to take your
time
screw at least scripting an outline you
know and really knowing what are the
points I want ahead and that's where
watching as many videos as you possibly
can that have been successful in doing
what you're trying to achieve comes in
I mean I watched so many Kickstarter
videos and I actually went and
transcribed them I probably transcribed
20 different Kickstarter videos the ones
that I thought were really good and I
broke him down and I broke them down my
structure and I broke them down my time
and I was like the best ones have done
this much in the first 30 seconds and
this much in the first three minutes and
are out by this point at four and a half
minutes and then I was shameless about
asking people for help looking at the
rough cut Sherrie canler who is is great
I mean I know you guys know who she is
you know we begged her to have a little
look at her at a rough cut which was
long which was a long rough cut it was
like eight minutes and she wisely said
cut that thing in half you know and and
we listened to her so I think that it's
you know after you've scripted it and
after you've created your first cut it's
getting feedback from people and it is
owing it's knowing what you feedback to
listen to and which feedback not listen
to to not listen to which all creatives
have a problem with you know if you
listen to everybody you're gonna
completely lose the creative vision in
the first place but if you don't listen
to the people who really know what
they're talking about
you better have a darn good reason and I
think that you know of all the notes
that we got I think sherry canler's were
some of the most that on and some of the
most useful so I'd be willing to hear
notes from others and then just polish
Polish polish I mean when you ask
somebody to watch your video you're
asking them to give up a chunk of their
time to consider helping you and
possibly writing you a check that's a
big-ass already you see you should not
be asking them in my opinion you know
with tape that sucks you know that
hasn't been thought through and that
doesn't mean that it has to be you know
100 percent perfectly polished sound and
amazing graphics and you know really
shout out in really expensive cameras it
just means that you have taken the time
and you've to make sure that your
passion and your ideas and what you're
asking for are clear and I think if we
could make it entertaining all the
better
you know but so so you do have to work
hard and I think we probably worked on
maybe two weeks and the Kickstarter
video before we launched it I was two
weeks but it was two weeks full-time I
mean that was like me like we were
talking earlier I was like me like 8:00
a.m. the 2:00 a.m. every day
transcribing videos
writing scripts experimenting with
graphics experimenting with music making
sure we have music that we have the
rights to use so you know and in two
weeks I for us I mean that's that's a
long time because we're we're pretty
fast so two weeks before us now would
have been probably like two months for
us when we first started if that makes
sense
well we assigned to do several shoots
but I think was the interesting point is
what you just described is the creative
process of any project you know what are
you writing a short or a feature or
doing a documentary you know you have to
do your research you have to outline you
have to write you have to shoot you have
the tinkering post you got to get you
know all the pieces together and then
you got to put it through a notes
process and really listen hard and make
sure you know so that's what we did is
we you know took all of our skills and
process that we do on our on their other
storytelling ventures and put it in this
video you know I don't I don't think it
is worth it to dismiss it as like oh
it's just a pitch video it's a big deal
you're asking people to support you it's
it has to represent you at your best
so if you're not willing to spend the
time and energy on making it the best
representation of you and your project
that you can that it can be then you're
selling yourself short
you